[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec maître
sébastien de l'orge avocat au barreau de
toulouse bonjour sébastien de l'orge
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france on
va parler avec vous de la légalité des
peines encourues pour ceux qui ne
respectent pas le confinement
je rappelle quelques données depuis le
23 mars une première infraction etc
sanctionnée par une amende de 135 euros
200 euros en cas de récidive dans les 15
jours puis à partir de quatre
verbalisations et ça et cela dans un
délai de 30 jours
cela devient un délit puni d'une amende
de 3750 euros est passible de six mois
d'emprisonnement
alors vous qui représentez des personnes
qui sont poursuivis précisément pour ce
délit
comment ça se passe quand on est en
infraction pour la quatrième fois
concrètement lorsqu'un traitement
la personne nous sort de chez elle elle
évolué et les verbaliser pour qu'elle me
sens ni revinois on constaterait la
prestation aux côtés gilles simon ne
saurait pas une forme aux prescriptions
est créée et est depuis en fait on va
s'apercevoir que de sept personnes a
déjà fait l'objet des verbalisations
donc au moins trois parce que c'est à
partir de la 4ème canton donc changé et
la personne est immédiatement en garde
de réponse et vous vous dites alors
comme d'autres de vos confrères que ce
délit de violation du confinement n'est
pas conforme à la constitution et porte
donc atteinte aux droits et aux libertés
pourquoi elle suit alors qu'on
retravaille qu'ils étaient faits à des
confrères % des cas les avocats de
france notamment et elle rappelle que
nous avons soulevés ediciones d un de
ceux des alors je dis procédure
particulière qui est rentré en libérant
des ministres et 1 et qui permet
d'adresser au jugement nous testions
dite prioritaire de constituer le juge
[Musique]
plusieurs critères
le câble au visage est ce que la loi en
question apparaît déjà l'objet et enfin
est ce que la question qui lui est posée
est dépourvu ou non de caractère scène
s'il juge recevable question il peut là
contre m à la chambre criminelle de la
cour de cassation elle-même a opéré un
filtre alors il va décider ou non de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
il se prononcera sur la
constitutionnalité des caisses qui pose
problème c'est le flou du décret qui
fixe les règles de déplacement
les chercheurs voulaient briser ce que
nous avons doublé nos tickets de
comparution au tribunal chez vous avec
actuellement 5es et justin aurait c'est
bien ceux des mots à nos sens des mots
sens de beaucoup de confrères
contrevient à au moins deux principes
majeurs
oui celui de légalité des délits et des
peines et le principe cardinal de la
présomption d'innocence
ces deux principes dépit du retard dans
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen et même les parties du blog
de constitution la première chez parce
que l'atteinte côtes entiers la liberté
individuelle est important parce qu'une
peine d'emprisonnement est susceptible
de il appartient au législateur
finalement de créer défini lundi c'est à
dire que le législateur ne saurait
méconnaître sa compétence renvoyer à un
décret définit d or c'est ce qui s'est
passé effectivement j'ai un article et
31 36-1 effectivement noire mais les
éléments constitutifs deux années figure
finalement dans le décret le 3 mars 2000
il avait indiqué se dévide applicable à
partir du moment où dans un délai de 30
jours
la personne n'aurait été harmonisées
pluie de trois ans
éditions d'organisation elles sont
définies par le décret donc la première
chose c'est que le statu quo de liberté
des musées des peines je vois que
certaines qualités mais là non c'est à
dire que celle ci doit être accessible
elle doit être révisée elle doit être
claire et elle doit être le droit pénal
et l'empathie pour deux raisons au moins
il s'agit de citoyens d'être en mesure
d'adapter sa conduite est immédiatement
savoir expliquer ce qui est permis et
envoie aussi évidemment de se prémunir
des risques d'arbitraire
c'est la finale ce qui est permis et ce
qui n'est pas permis c'est ce que vous
dites ça doit être claire et sur
l'attestation pour vous c'est pas clair
alors l'article 2 du décret prévoit 80
et de permission aux qui nous permet de
déroger aux obligations ciblées de
rester chez soi problème c'est que ces
permissions
elles sont effectivement peu claires les
chances que tout un chacun et pas besoin
d'être juriste on s'est interrogé sur le
centre et il est sur une chambre de ses
paires meeting qu'elle était entachée
d'une première nécessité qu'est-ce-qui
familiales impérieuses
j'ai finalement laissée à la libre
appréciation de l'agent et ça permet pas
aux citoyens les doit régler leur
conduite et celles non pré mais n'est
pas contrainte sp d'arbitrages
ministériels carrière semble assez vite
compte du caractère qui voulaient obscur
de ce décret et leurs alliés donc il est
généralement donné des instructions
alors si c'est tout à fait possible
parce que effectivement la langue bnl on
a besoin qu'elle soit destinée c'est
clair mais rejette la loi ne peut jamais
embrassé cette situation il est toujours
question
c'est sûr alors c'est effectivement
c'est possible mais c'est à la condition
que l'exécutif ne rajoute pas des
conditions ne sont pas prévues par la
loi
or là c'est taxer les stations en elle
même telle que proposée sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur
elle est obligatoire or c'est que non
puisque le deuxième paragraphe du yacht
de l'article 3 du décret ou dit
finalement que les personnes souhaitant
bénéficier de l'une des exceptions
doivent s'unir lors de leurs
déplacements hors de leurs comités d'un
document leur permettant de justifier le
déplacement considéré entre dans le
champ de mines des exceptions il s'agit
donc d'un document et non pas
précisément l'attestation qui a été mise
en ligne sur le site
je vous dis tiens pourquoi pas ce qu'on
a entendu de tous on nous a dit il faut
pas coché plus d'un motif
on le devine il ne faut pas écrire la
démentir cette espèce l'attestation avec
un crayon à papier mais avec landrin des
lipides etc etc
ce sont des conditions qui nous a été
finalement à la loi et le risque
d'arbitraire live à temps et les huskies
avaient le dernier geste a été entendu
par la commission des lois millions de
véhicules eux ils avaient été cédés à
700 mille sept cents interrogé sur le
caractère flou et sur quelques faits
divers le monde histoire castaner
déclaré je ne dit pas qu'il y ait des
terreurs et c'est parce que je ne
doutais pas qu'il y aurait des erreurs
et j'ai veillé à ce que le délai de
contestation de sa contravention
initialement de 40 jours c'est là où la
présomption d'innocence n'est pas
respectée m d'état pas un problème de
violation manifeste de la présomption
d'innocence pourquoi parce que et
christophe restait merde
le débit mais finalement quand est
compromis
à partir du moment où notifie cette
organisation avait invité les musulmans
un jour il est toujours présumé innocent
or est la nôtre et nous plaît que les
régimes qu'une 3 violations en 30 ans
est in qui compte c'est qu'il y ait des
erreurs on dit qu'il est une possibilité
de roue mais finalement ce télescope
la cour de cassation a trois mois pour
transmettre ou pas au conseil
constitutionnel
ces délais seront respectés selon vous
dans ce contexte sanitaire et comment ça
va se passer concrètement vous êtes
confiant quant à l'annulation de ce
décret de la loi
confiant malgré la loi les championnes
et de la protestation and site internet
qu'elle invente des traités dans les
plus brefs délais dans le respect des
droits des parties
elle évite le conseil constitutionnel
dans un premier temps elle n'est indiqué
que ne se considéraient plus tenu le
délai de trois mois pour signer sur des
questions il en a remis en eau
bouillante
il faut espérer que étant donné est un
nageur aux droits et libertés garantis
par la constitution des listes
on a très rapidement s'il est question
de lui transmis il ya effectivement de
possibles dont certains ont déjà repéré
[Musique]
correctionnel de rennes havas laissez
vous séduire
un prévenu tu étais réponse à une
question fichiers fichiers doc
semble-t-il et max rêve est pas vrai
mais il reste des questions épineuses à
savoir le nouveau fichier
on serait la ministre aurait progression
mais enfin si mais sinon il pouvoir
mentionner des organisations antérieur
[Musique]
le taux moyen de tester ces cheminements
après externe
c'est bien pourquoi parce que finalement
cette chronique intime la présomption
d'innocence
figure bien évidemment par la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme dans
toutes lés joies d'une france il aussi
dernière question sébastien de larges
votre façon de travailler a changé
depuis ce confinement de travail et
beaucoup par vidéoconférence avec vos
clients
est-ce qu'on peut les défendre
correctement en procédant ainsi faut-il
craindre que ce cette méthode perdure
même après le confinement alors il faut
toujours un j'ai pris de l'expérience
nous montre et c'est tout
les déceptions qui sont censés être
kronis voir dans quelle mesure elles ne
viennent à affecter le droit commun et
généreront si l'on peut comprendre que
les vidéo conférences
on peut craindre que l suite ltd d'état
d'urgence
finalement c'est devenu en france durant
ce continue à se produire
alors pourquoi cet impôt mais c'est un
problème parce que on ne défend
quelqu'un demande étant physiquement je
pense que j'ai bien quelques uns le
continent raison devant soi parce que la
même vous téléphonez à voeckler dans
l'est dans les prisons c'est ce qui se
passe actuellement uniquement s'ils
s'imposent
difficulté c'est la base entre la
pollution d'un avocat est la personne la
confiance et c'est la confidentialité
qui permet la confidentialité qui permet
la confiance reste or là un téléphone
quelqu'un que je n'ai vu que vous voyez
pas une ligne dont cette bible d'être
écouté une personne ne sait pas s'il y
avait effectivement c'est là encore ce
ne sont pas des conditions permettre
d'exercer
merci beaucoup sélaciens de larges
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france je rappelle évidemment qu'il faut
bien sûr respecter les règles du
confinement
restez chez vous et restez avec nous
l'info à suivre
[Musique]